jessica is joining us from south
carolina live with a question hi Jessica
how are you I'm good how are you it's
good to be here good to have you how can
I help so my sister and I are graduating
college soon I'll be done in May and
she'll finish in December and we
currently have no credit and everyone
continues to tell us that we're not
living in the real world you know we
need credit to buy a house or to rent an
apartment so what would be your advice
to tell them because it kind of makes us
angry we know it can be done that we
don't need credit or what is your advice
as far as building credit goes yeah good
question
well um one of the things I've
discovered is is that as we've talked to
all these millionaires in the
millionaire research that we did was one
of the correlating statistical facts are
character qualities about millionaires
is they really don't listen to broke
people about money and so um that's one
thing you could just say is go well you
know you know you know any money I want
to take your financial advice right and
you can be nice about it but you meet a
key if you want to it's kind of fun but
you know so in your mind you kind of
need to get that and just go that's like
I would not go into a personal trainer
and there's 500 pounds I would go I
don't think I'm in the right place you
know I don't want to talk to broke
people about money right and so you just
kind of think this through and I one of
the things that happened to me when I
went broke emotionally and spiritually
was I lost all of my need to impress
people and to do what they said and I
heard and we used to call it barber
chair advice and you know you go in the
barber shop and they've got it they got
advice on everything it seems like
barbers they know everything they know
more than anybody else and so you can
get advice or you know it's bartender
advice I think right now my sister and I
said we bet pay cash for our cars before
we went to college and we both got full
tuition scholarships intercrop some when
we graduate we don't know a dime and
just want to get out you know step out
into the world so far ahead of everybody
else you know and these people that are
criticizing you you know I mean you're
part of the student loan epic debacle I
you don't think I'm smart I sorry it's
kind of ridiculous so yeah but I mean
here's the truth you know people still
say it to me me I mean so I mean that if
they say it to me you know they're gonna
say to you that's nice
you know so but the the actual technical
answer but you're not going to convince
stupid people okay but the technical
answer is I won't argue with stupid
people but the answer is yes you can get
an apartment as a matter of fact you
know Anthony O'Neill talks about this
with the youth all the time and it comes
up with high school students of college
students when she speaks to almost every
week so much so and I think he posted it
on YouTube I used it the other day in a
shoot I don't know if we posted it yet
or not but it was absolutely incredible
he sat down camera in front of him and
started dialing apartment complexes in
our area and it's an affluent area and
in a middle-class area and in a
lower-class area right and he just kept
down with him and dialing him and
dialing him hey I'm moving to Nashville
I got no credit score but I got no dad
Kent will you work with me can you help
me get in the apartment did you know
every one of them said they would work
with him huh now they didn't he didn't
say I have a bad credit score he said I
have no credit score like you yes sir
right and you know everyone I'm someone
said you have to be put a bigger deposit
down which by the way when you leave you
get the deposit back if you don't tear
up the apartment right so that's not
lost money it's lost cash right then but
it's not lost money so sorry it cost you
more ultimately so and some of them said
yeah we'll figure it out I mean just
come on in and you know we'll look at it
but we just want to make sure you can
pay the bill that that's all they're
worried about I was under the impression
a whole bunch of them won't turn you
down just period on credit score right
and I guess that's what the rest of the
world makes it that way and they believe
it yes you know and of course on a house
you can do with Churchill mortgage or
other good mortgage companies the thing
called manual underwriting now what
manual underwriting is instant
non-manual underwriting is the mortgage
company looks at one number FICO score
and they go big enough or not big enough
done okay if you don't have that they
got to actually look at the human being
and say do you have a job do you have a
down payment do you have
walking around since you know I mean
they actually have that's not one of
them but you know they actually have to
do real like when I got in the real
estate business in 1978 a thousand years
ago that's how mortgages were made there
was no FICO score yes banks actually
looked to see if the people had a job if
they had a downpayment if they were
steady on their job and they did pull
their credit report back there to see if
they paid their bills right but that's
all they did
back and that was regular underwriting
for a mortgage they didn't just look at
one number which a monkey can do that
number big enough number not big enough
you know I mean it's like stupid the
dumbing down the mortgage business but
anyway you can find mortgage companies
that will actually say okay you paid
your apartment rent earlier on time
you're putting a good down payment down
you have this job and you're steady on
this job for six months we can verify
all of those things and when we verify
all of those things that's called
manually underwriting the loan and Twala
you got you yes sir but for years my mom
has listened to you and has encouraged
us to follow and do the same and says
I'm going out into the world that's my
plan to follow your ways to stay out of
death you're doing great you're rock
stars both of you a sharp sharp young
ladies I don't have to talk to you thank
you for coming by